all right so here's my list of the top
ten anticipated movies of 2020
I almost said 19 these are the 10 movies
I'm looking forward to this year they're
not in any particular order it's like at
first they started being in
chronological order and then then
they're not it just fell off the rails
in terms of chronology you see a lot of
movies on this be like last Jeremy it's
true a lot of movies on this list or
quirky they look like they might be fun
and it might otherwise be entertaining
do these have a high probability of
sucking but man if they're good not
gonna do this set up Babel too much I
feel like a lot of you know me and since
this is very informal no need for the
epic countdown I'm just gonna start
listen 'mom first once the gentleman
which actually comes out this month
January movie January movie it's it's a
movie directed by Guy Ritchie it's a
crime movie directed by Guy Ritchie it's
funny because I haven't loved a guy
Ritchie movie in 20 years since snatch
but every time I feel like he's going
back to return to form I always kind of
get disappointed but I always end up
being excited it's a crime movie
directed by Guy Ritchie starring Matthew
McConaughey I have to give this a shot
and I just it's in my nature to look
forward to it next up the Invisible Man
this movie could suck good very well but
judging by the trailer I feel like this
Invisible Man movies better than
anything Universal dark universe was
going to do that they're now no longer
doing this is what Invisible Man movie
should be someone who turns invisible
and is a psychological thriller because
he's driving someone insane and no one's
gonna believe her because there was an
invisible guys tormenting you right I've
always been interested in the prospect
of what would people do if they became
invisible
I feel like translucent from the boys is
probably the most accurate
representation of it this could be good
hope it doesn't suck next up a quiet
place to because a quiet place was one
of the surprises of 2018 I didn't need a
sequel it was inevitable that it was
going to get a sequel after its success
and now we're getting a sequel a sequel
where I haven't even seen the trailer
that's how much I'm looking forward to
this movies if I'm really looking
forward to it I'm gonna be like I don't
want to watch the trailer I don't want
to know anything and that's a quiet
place to which is relevant for what I'm
gonna say next cuz what I'm going to say
next might have been addressed in the
trailer cuz I do think a quiet place one
just lends itself to being scarier
because when you have these things that
are so ready to kill you if you make P
but in a quiet place to now we know how
to take him out that's just less scary
but hopefully that intensity remains
John Krasinski's back to direct I'm
happy about that ring on the sequel but
not the sequel itis next Wonder Woman
1984 why because
Wonder Woman was pretty sweet well
two-thirds of that movie the last act is
clearly the weakest part of Wonder Woman
but patty Jenkins did a good job with
that movie she's back to directness my
concern with Wonder Woman 1984 is that
the Steve Trevor things just gonna be
kind of played out and there isn't gonna
be a good reason for him to be there he
might be this clunky part of the movie I
hope not but it is a concern I have in
my mind but Wonder Woman 1984 for sure
next up no time to die which is a new
Bond movie Bond movies are kind of 50/50
for me but they are undeniably iconic
and I'm looking forward to this because
this is Daniel Craig's farewell as bond
and the dude has made a couple of great
Bond movies a couple of not-so-great
Bond movies but Casino Royale is
pound-for-pound my favorite Bond movie
that's ever happened we do have concerns
absolutely I feel like they're warranted
concerns because Hollywood doesn't seem
to excel in the world of subtlety and
nuance a case in point it's been said
and announced that this is a James Bond
film from me to Aaron leaving people to
speculate what the hell that actually
means again a subtlety is about what I
expected from Hollywood I just feel like
if they wanted to have the greatest
impact with that quest they would have
just written the movie filmed the movie
done the movie release the movie but the
movie speak for itself
like I understand in the movie he's no
longer part of the agency he's not
double-oh-seven because they gave the
number to someone else because why
wasn't that so I get that but I want him
to fundamentally still feel like James
Bond
I want it to feel like James Bond
because James Bond has to have that
sexiness to him right James Bond without
the sexiness you know that's pretty much
mission impossible not that Mission
Impossible isn't great not that Tom
Cruise ain't sexy I mean I hope I look
like that when I'm 50 to something so
there's concerns because as I've said
before Hollywood seems to seems to have
all the subtlety of a chainsaw so we
will see how it goes but to the point
this is Daniel Craig's farewell as James
Bond and he has earned it next up is
ghostbusters afterlife I really like the
trailer for this one it has a different
tone from the original Ghostbusters but
does look to pay respect to that
universe I don't know that I can say
anything here that I didn't already say
in my video about the trailer itself
recreating the nostalgia from the
earlier movies does not make for a good
movie this doesn't look like it's trying
to do that it looks like it's going for
a different thing like it's trying to be
its own movie and stand on its own two
legs but as a sequel to the previous
Ghostbusters movie and/or game I know
I've got a lot of comments in the
comment section next up mank mank is one
of the movies that actually did almost
fly under the radar
then I found out about it is one of
those movies that on paper it sounds
amazing it's a new David Fincher film I
like David Fincher stars Gary Oldman
great cast and it's a biopic about the
friction filled creation of Citizen Kane
well more specifically from what I heard
the writer of Citizen Kane conflicting
with Orson Welles to get writing credit
for Citizen Kane so it's a biopic by a
great director revolving around an
iconic film with a great cast point it
just sounds like a biopic I would
probably really enjoy speaking of iconic
and classy we're gonna lean right into
Bill and Ted face the music yeah I don't
even care this is like any band reunion
it may be great it may suck and
disappoint but as far as I'm concerned
the wild stallions reunion is the
greatest band reunion since the Beach
Boys reunion went to that concert with
my dad it was amazing I don't even Bill
and Ted is such an 80s movie even at
first when I heard about it I was
skeptical and then I saw a picture so
it's like okay okay is bogus journey
Canon is death gonna be in it I don't
know interested I'm even I'm theorizing
about Bill and Ted next up is Tennant
Tennant is Christopher Nolan's new film
I loved most of Christopher Nolan's
movies you can't deny the talent of the
guy and the trailer too is funny because
people were comparing it to Inception it
kind of hurt my did me don't judge don't
judge too harshly anyway but it kind of
reminded me of that episode of Red Dwarf
for they land in that town and they're
like oh my jaw hurts all my knuckles
hurt because they got into a bar fight
but the town was it was like a backwards
planet and so they had all the damage as
a fight but it hadn't happened yet then
the fight takes place and it happens
backwards and like their jaw gets fixed
and their hands don't hurt anymore yeah
that's what I thought of when I saw the
trailer for Christopher Nolan's new film
well I love it I don't know but I'll
always look forward to a new Nolan film
and last number 10 on the list which is
funny because I think it comes out the
latest in the year of all these movies
so this list is at least book ended with
soonest one first
latest one last but it's dune and I love
doing the dune movie that came out in
the 80s it is a flawed movie for sure
but I'm still so nostalgic Lee wrapped
up and it's such a part of my childhood
I still love it and did evil a new vis
the director which I never know if I'm
pronouncing his name right point is he
directed Blade Runner 2049 and I was
glad to see that he didn't try to take
Blade Runner and make it an action
franchise or anything he kept Blade
Runner feeling like Blade Runner so I
really feel like he's the guy for the
job to take on dune in fact he doesn't
actually have to follow the 1980s movie
he should by all accounts follow the
look so I'm interested he's gonna make
it totally like the 1984 I think it was
84 dune moving or is he like no I'm
doing the books don't know looking
forward to finding out point is I do
feel like he is the guy for the job and
that is my personal list in no
particular order of my top 10
anticipated movies for this year 2020
looking forward to them looking forward
to another year of movies this year as
every year it'll go down like this if
I'm lucky a couple movies on this list
might actually end up on my top 10
favorite movies of 2020 list I make at
the end of the year some will be
disappointing some will suck but the
year as a whole I have a lot of
surprises so here's to another year
again thank you for sticking around for
another year I hope you stick around for
this one sorry I wasn't really in a rush
to get this up on the 2nd of January or
anything just I knew The Grudge wasn't
one of my anticipated movies of the year
so I didn't really have a rush to do it
before I saw The Grudge but as for you
what are your top 10 anticipated movies
a 2020 or 5 or however many you want to
list whatever they are whatever you
think comment below let me know and as
always if you like what you've seen here
and you want to see more click right
here to see more
[Music]